الاخطبوط بول في المانيا القط اخيل في
روسيا وغيرهما من الحيوانات لطالما كانت
محور الاهتمام في توقعات نتائج كاس العالم
وبطولات عالميه اخرى لكن انظمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي تخطف المشهد في مونديال العام
2022 في لندن يتنبا معهد الانتورين لعلوم
البيانات والذكاء الاصطناعي بفوز منتخب
البرازيل بالنسخه الحاليه لكاس العالم
الباحثون اختبروا الاحتمالات مئه الف مره
25% من التجارب كانت لصالح منتخب الساون
اما اقرب المنافسين للفوز بالبطوله بعد
البرازيل حسب نفس النموذج كان منتخب
بلجيكا بنسبه 19% في النمسا يتفقوا نموذج
ذكاء اصطناعي اخر من جامعه انستروك مع
النموذج البريطاني وخوارزمياته ترجح كافه
البرازيل لتحقيقه البطوله
اخيرا وعلى عكس النموذجين السابقين يتوقع
نظام شركه التامين البريطانيه لغزوف لندن
فوزا انجلترا على البرازيل في المباراه
النهائيه وهو نفس النموذج الذي توقع فوز
المانيا بمونديال 2014 على فرنسا ايضا في